When we talk about processor performance, we typically
talk about its speed, how many instructions per
second can it finish, but we also have
to consider its fabrication cost and the power
consumption it will have. Lower fabrication costs allow
us to put processors that are more powerful
into devices that cannot be expensive, like refrigerators
and watches and all sorts of other things.
Low power consumption is important not only because
of the cost of electricity, but also because
it translates into longer battery life and smaller
form factors for things like cell phones. So what
we really want is that the speed of
a processor doubles over something like two years, that
the cost of this twice as fast processor
stays about the same, and that the power consumption
of this twice as fast processor stays about the same as before. But we don't
have to use technology improvement to get
this. We can get, instead, a smaller improvement
in speed, let's say 1.1x, for about half the cost as the original processor, and
let's say about half the power consumption
of the original processor. Which one of these
do you want? Well, it depends what kind of computer you're building. So, one
of the jobs of computer architects is
really to figure out, given that the technology
can provide either this or this, or
something in between them. Actually, there are
many more options. Which one do I really want for a specific type of computer?